je vous annonce est une surprise
j'espère que vous allez leur réserver un
accueil digne de ce nom car c'est dans
la rolls royce de monsieur labiche que
nous accueillons aujourd'hui
tara king et john steed en personne se
battre et marées et linda thorson dans
une rolls royce qu'à s'embraser
l'inquiétude
mais maintenant vous dire que linda est
une habituée de cette émission est venu
nous voir à diverses reprises à
plusieurs occasions mais là c'est un
anniversaire que nous fêtons pouvez vous
asseoir can you say die en place nos
problèmes voilà à côté n'est pas
tellement comme partout mais nous
pouvons rester debout
wickens tana et puis voilà ouais voyez
tout autour de nous regarder il y à des
bouteilles de champagne a légué aux
cassettes jadden champigny à des jeux de
lumières paris match
hier vingt ans regarder si c'est moi
regarder ça j'aimerais linda ce si tu
veux bien que tu nous racontes
dans quelles conditions au tout début
hu dans quelles conditions est ce qu'on
a proposé le rôle de chapeau melon et
bottes de cuir est votre première
rencontre can you explain meilleure
phase melingui bébé c'était c'était
avant le tournage
il ya une semaine
jeter avec beaucoup de producteurs et il
veut savoir s'il ya quelque chose entre
nous un camé str8 carizzma je sais pas
quoi et j'étais dans la chambre us des
bons sega patrick macnee et je t'aime
russe de tout de suite à sa voisine love
by former ligne où tout lui tout de
suite oui oui et toujours après et
jusque ce moment et après tout cas c'est
une bonne chose de jeu je ne parle pas
français de tous darline de c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai de tous mais elle
était comme ce qu'ils valent monsieur
plus belle encore après 20 ans
heureusement vous ne parlait pas
français mais jean patrick kane you
explain mais de ceux comme stan sick of
du shooting de série et 3 quel sens vous
riez beaucoup touché la rondelle on
s'est dit amusé explaining léché fioul
ou un chalet de suisse elle a peut-être
de très beaux yeux bleus mai 2010 et
séguéla et au cna est né est m'a fallu
neuf ans est là et pour faire chaque
moment et pas de dewsbury qu'au départ
on l'appelait ainsi avengers
nous sommes extrêmement reconnaissants
après tant d'années en france mène à la
série il soit resté aussi populaire
qu'elle était au départ
merci au cours de cet accueil très
chaleureux et l'expression mauvaise